blade smith's congratulations you've
made it to the final round of this
competition
now we're sending you back to your home
forge just to recreate an iconic weapon
from history
the kybio
felisa both functional and ornate the
fleece is the traditional sword of the
cable berbers of north africa ranging in
size from daggers to sabers over three
feet in length fleeces are single edged
a straight back and cutting edge that
tapers the long needle-like tip and
unusual weight and balance make it ideal
for tearing through male armor commonly
worn throughout the 19th century the
fleecea was deeply rooted in the
berber's faith and is complete with
complex geometric designs an animal head
pommel
good luck we'll see you in five days
my name is colin sage i'm 27 years old
from louisville kentucky and i've been
smithing for about five years now i'm
intimidated by will willis's hair then
it changes it's like a chameleon this
locks they're gonna distract me maybe he
has him down maybe it's pulled back i
don't know
it's it's gonna be tough
ready to forge in fire
oh got that a little too hot
so i just
left the steel in a little too long
it got so hot and started fracturing
i've got to be careful never taking my
eyes off that baby
so trying to get to the two inches wide
at the base of the blade and at the
belly is not fun it's getting extremely
thin got me a little worried you know a
extremely thin blade
is gonna be prone to warp in the quench
i'm digging a freaking trench i gotta
get this thing he traded as fast as i
can this is a quench trench there is
very little precision
in what's happening right now
this has to work if it doesn't work i'm
i'm just done i'm out i'm finished i'm
going to attempt a vertical quench
because that should keep the blade from
warping
razzle dazzle baby
i'm fully expecting this thing to be all
warped and crazy and it's straight
the verdict right now is
is i'm really tired that's the
verdict my name is daniel casey and i'm
a full-time traditional knife and
gunsmith i'm going to do well in this
competition because i stick to
traditional methods and it really shows
through my work
steel being super high carbon steel like
it is it's not moving a whole lot even
at a pretty high heat
so i've got my work cut out for me
no doubt about it
there's still a little bit of polishing
that i would like to do before i can
call the blade done
so the main thing that i do have some
concern about is the actual hardening of
the blade
i've definitely been putting it off as
long as possible because it could either
warp on me it could get a crack in the
blade
listening for that ping
trying to make sure that it stayed
straight
it's definitely not as straight as i was
hoping
and there's no way to fix that
so we're gonna roll with it we're moving
on
so i decided i'm gonna do i think an
eagle's head with my handle material
instead of part of the blade material
it's gonna cut a little bit more weight
off of the sword which will be a good
thing so it may work out in my favor the
handle section does seem very small for
the size of the sword but we're trying
to stick close to the original it's
definitely a knife handle on a sword but
uh i put a nice palm swell in there i
think that's gonna help a lot with the
grip on the sword i'm confident that the
handle will work out well to see what
kind of lethal damage your weapon will
do well deliver slashes and thrusts on
this ballistic stummy
colin you're up first you ready have fun
let's do this to help me today i'm
bringing back one of mark ida colley's
chief instructors please welcome u.s
staff sergeant chris bans
[Music]
all right colin your cabil fleesah is
very sharp on the initial thrust it
penetrated deep and easily through this
whole ballistics dummy the handle is
comfortable it's easy to slash in and
thrust out overall
it will kill
good job
thank you sir all right daniel your turn
you ready yes sir
all right daniel your weapon is wicked
sharp
on the initial thrust it penetrated deep
and on the way out with your belly being
forward it lacerates out easily
now
because you have such a very skinny
handle right here and there is no pummel
with a counterweight all the weight is
in front the balance just makes the
blade rotate with a small handle like
this but in terms of damage
it will kill thank you good job
all right bladesmiths next up is a
strength test
bladesmith to test the strength and
durability of your kabul fleecer i'll be
smashing them into these terracotta pots
edge first remember this test is all
about where the parts do your blades and
not the blades due to the parts caroline
you're up first you ready yes sir all
right
[Music]
awesome man
well colin your blade held up
beautifully the uh edge
looks like it never saw it there terra
cotta did a great job well done thank
you sir daniel you're up you ready i'm
ready
[Music]
well daniel your edge held up pretty
well i rubbed my fingers across i can
feel just a little bit of a wire edge
but nothing major but my my big concern
this handle
it's so small that i had a tough time
indexing it but it's beautifully carved
edge held up beautifully all right well
done thank you sir
[Music]
all right gentlemen you survived our
kill test and our strength test now the
sharpness test
test the sharpness of that blade and to
see if it still has an edge i'll be
cutting through these fish
a clean sharp blade should pass right
through those fish the dull blade is
going to knock those fish out of the way
or give us a jagged torn cut colin you
ready yes sir okay i'm just thinking
please just slice through this thing
all right colin right off it's
definitely a sharp blade it cut very
nicely
your handle is a bit on the fat side
but it's definitely a cutter good job
thank you sir
daniel are you ready yes okay great
i feel that colin and i are still neck
and neck
i think that i've got a good edge on
[Music]
all right daniel this blade is wicked
sharp
and those cuts
you can see they just blew right through
the fish my problem is this is
so small i had to fight to keep it in my
hand
these felicia often have a very small
handle but what saves that is having
that pummel keeping your hand from
coming off the back of that blade
it's an amazing cutter it's just very
difficult to hold on to
daniel collins there can only be one
forged and fire champion
and that champion is
colin
congratulations you are a new forged and
fire champion
daniel your sword didn't make the cut
please surrender your blade
i am disappointed of course that i
didn't win but i'm absolutely proud of
the work i did here if anything i think
that this fuels my fire to work harder
and do better
colin congratulations you are our new
forged and fire champion and that's the
title that comes with a check for 10
grand good job buddy
as far as your animal head pummel i'm
gonna go ahead and say it's probably an
underdog
well colin please present your weapon to
the judges
will willis out here telling me i'm a
champion
can you believe it
a champ i can't believe it
fortune fire champion out here
[Music]
you